okay now digital eye strain affects six
out of 10 American workers and increases
the likelihood of experiencing dry eye
symptoms such as blurry vision and
irritation now while there is no cure
for dry eye disease there are Simple
Solutions to find relief from dry eye
symptoms check this out ophthalmologist
Dr Laura Perryman says staring at your
screen lowers your blink rate by half
creating dry spots on your eyes your
blank is critically important for
spreading your Terra film re-wetting
your cornea providing a little break
from the drying evaporative load when
that staring time exceeds this tear
stability times little dry spots develop
and that sets the stage for chronic dry
eye disease but relief is close at hand
if you know which eye drops to get I
like very much the sustained complete
preservative-free lubricating eye drops
for several specific reasons number one
it provides fast hydration for that
sensitive eye it has Nano lifted cereals
to help lower the tear evaporation load
on the eye and a recent study showed
that what just one drop can provide up
to eight hours of symptom relief learn
more at sustain.com
okay I think I have the opposite problem
what is that your eyes watery eyes oh my
eyes sometimes I'm like
it's hard to yeah I don't need drops for
that I assume it's hard when you live in
the desert you would think that everyone
would have dry eyes but I just have the
thing where I cannot see for distances
so I'll see someone down the hall I'll
be like hi I don't know who you are but
hello it's the thought that comes yeah I
still said hi we'll be back
[Music]